my dad came over from Jamaica and set up
his own HMO so it's in my roots and I
came to a one pound course it literally
changed my life within the year I've
been able to get vibrant to rents and
bringing in about 3K a month when you
have a business partner it goes beyond
connecting with the pal size how do you
collect outside the mentality of society
is so warped and is set up in such a way
that's going to keep people poor from
working four and a half days to then
give myself the option of just going
back into a moment two days property
worked since being in the academy I've
made my money back three times over how
do you manage to juggle because you're
still working you've got your property
business how do you juggle all that and
be a mom
congrats on your success in property but
also you're having a baby next month I
am having a baby next month thank you I
still can't believe that you are due in
a few weeks because you look like three
months pregnant thank you but I
definitely feel like I'm as pregnant as
I am though yeah definitely the way it
is there but thank you for the
confidence compliment well you're
looking amazing I I had to drag you to
come on the show you did you did not
want to come on today I didn't want to
come on today what was it that made you
agree to come on winners on a Wednesday
do you know what to seize the moment
when opportunities appeared just take
them and don't allow fear to dictate
what you choose to do yeah and it's
funny I think I was listening to a
message of a motivational message before
I got yours and it's like seize
opportunities they'll come take them and
then when you message I was like okay
okay
but you've achieved great things in
property and also within the academy
Network Everybody Talks so highly of you
I mean every Mastermind your name will
come up somewhere down the line but oh
I'm already said this well Lamar help me
with this so what was it that made you
get into property in the first place
I've always had a passion for property
and when I think about my roots my dad
you know came over from Jamaica and set
up his own HMO and was renting out his
room so it's in my route so it was
always there and I thought well how do I
do it how do I get into it and then the
opportunity presents itself when I was
on maternity leave with my last baby and
I came to a one pound course my friend
Rowan need to invited me to one pound
course for rent to rent and I thought I
have no idea what this is but I'll just
rock up I don't you know a rock top and
literally I thought oh my gosh this is
my entry point in I don't need to have
thousands and thousands upon you know of
Pals to be able to get into property and
I thought amazing so went to one pound
course and then signed on to the boot
camp and that was a week-long and it's
changed my it literally changed my life
it gave me a a an opportunity to be able
to get cash flow to be able to then
build bigger so I then went on from that
to find an amazing business partner in
the academy called Isabella and we just
really connect not just because we're
both good in business but just connects
on a human level and for me that's
important when you're looking for a
business partner yeah and we've got
three rent events together and I've got
two more of my husbands So within a year
I've been able to get five renter rents
and bringing in about 3K a month yeah
that's incredible and you've sort of
systemized them quite well as well
haven't you yeah we don't have a channel
manager so I Channel manage them but I
just find it so much easier so yeah and
it works around everything else that I
do in life how many hours a week do you
spend managing the five rentals yeah I
would say probably an hour or just under
an hour per day so in total that's about
seven hours just under seven hours but a
week which is like nothing complete an
employee job yeah and now you're
transitioning into buy refill obviously
Finance yes and what I love about your
your story is the the passion and the
reason behind it and you know just
talking with you I know we spent a
couple of days together a few weeks back
at my house yes um doing a couple of
days of coaching talk about your vision
for what you're wanting to do within by
refurbishory Finance yeah so I know I've
always been called to work with young
people and aside for property I'm a
child psychologist and I've always just
wanted to help young people that have
experienced trauma and so I always
thought how can I marry property and my
purpose so one things I want to do is
build hmos and be able to provide
accommodation for young people whether
it's those that are in care or mother
and baby placement so just being able to
marry that passion of helping those to
be able to just set up their own lives
and show them that they can do anything
and it's not they're not down and out
but it's about opportunity and knowing
how to take action and just having the
network so literally that's that is my
purpose definitely and I'm looking
forward to seeing how that comes to
fruition yeah
and how do you find like you've already
got two kids yeah
with the third on the way I mean how how
do you manage to
juggle because you're still working as a
educational psychologist that's right
yeah I needed at least a couple days on
on that you've got your own business my
own consultancy yeah as a psychologist
you've got your property business where
in total how many properties have you
got in total is it is it five or seven
um I've got five properties in total
plus um one which is a um a buy to let
with my husband yeah yeah so you've got
six houses yeah which you're managing
running how do you juggle all that and
and be a mom yeah it's a really good
question and I think one of the things
that I was really drawn to when I um
came to the course was somebody called
hustling and I was like how do you merge
being a mum life and managing this so
what I realized it's about how you
organize your time and also not being
fearful to just try something new and
just having a good support network I
have to give an amazing shout out to my
mum who has just been a Lifeline I've
got key people my mum my husband who
believed in what I was doing and they
didn't think it was mad because
sometimes people can think are you you
gonna do this are you crazy but they
believed in the vision and they just
supported me so that's how I managed to
do it my husband's amazing Jason and my
mum has been such a great source of
support yeah that is so important and I
think a lot of the thing that you know a
story that I hear a lot with people
coming on Wednesday is my family thought
I was crazy they didn't believe me but
for you your mom bought into the vision
how did you manage to convince her or
what was it that she saw about about
property about you that made her buy-in
yeah great question and because my mom's
the older Generations she's in her 80s
but what she said to me is she's she
always wanted going to property herself
but she never created the opportunity
she had fear and she said lamara I like
the fact that you just want to take the
risk and do it so she goes I just want
to support you if it means that I'm you
know caring for the kids whilst you're
out doing the courses and looking for
things I'll support you in that way so
because I think it she didn't get to do
it herself she could see that I had that
driving she just wanted to help to
facilitate that so I kind of kept it
just to my mum not sharing it with
others in the family because I I would
think I was mad so I just really weighed
up who I shared what with and at what
time and I felt there was wisdom in that
and I think with other people who know
now it's because they see and when they
see they ask questions and I'm happy to
share and say yeah this is how you do it
you know so it's been more of a thing of
c and then say but with those that I
knew that would encourage me I was able
to trust them with it before it came to
fruition makes sense and I do think
you've got to be careful who you talk
about business to with like if you're
talking to people who you know don't get
it their employment minded people don't
even try because they're just gonna
bring you down and there's some people
that you can spend two hours with but
maybe not two days that's right that's
right and the Synergy is just there yeah
and it's funny I was at my mom's the
other day and a friend of hers was there
but we just had the Synergy and we were
talking about property where we hadn't
seen each other for years we were back
and forth in that hour just talking
about but we laughed because we said we
both got it and not everybody do you
have that synergy yeah so yeah it's just
weighing up when who how yeah yeah talk
to me about how the Business Partnership
with Isabella came into fruition
Isabella is well known again on the
academy she's amazing a good friend of
mine
um talk to me about how that came about
so I remember I was at an academy dinner
and we were sat on the same table and we
just connected about life Samuel we were
talking about Rich Dad Poor Dad and she
was saying she'd given her son a copy to
read and I was like oh my gosh I'd no
longer that book and it shifted my mind
and so we just connected about our life
and then we saw each other again at
another dinner she goes oh The more I've
got this deal and I was like oh okay
let's have a look at this still and when
we looked at the numbers I was quite
interested and so I went down to see her
spent laughing with her and her family
and we just found a connection and felt
we're going to the deal together but
importantly we just worked well together
there was something about us respecting
one another just as humans respecting
our lives outside of property but also
working well with the vision in property
and we almost naturally found our
individual roles within the business we
just worked well together and it just
came together quite easily and her
husband's very Hands-On so is mine so
her husband would do a lot of the DIY
Jay my husband would do a bit it just
really worked Samuel so for me it's
about when you have a business partner
it goes beyond connecting with the pal
size how do you collect outside because
when things go wrong it's knowing how do
you resolve that stuff and can you do it
amicably talk through it problem solve
and I can do all that with her so it's
an honor to work with her what's it like
being a woman in business because that's
something I'll I'll never know firsthand
is it do you think it's different
definitely Samuel I use my eyes to
observe and I see how men are received
differently to women yeah I even had a
conversation the other day with them one
of the landlords and my husband when he
became part of the conversation the
landlord responded so differently today
and I said Jay did you notice how
different he responded she goes no Lamar
it's in your head I said no I feel that
for some reason men seem to have this
more weight that's held or or you can
um command a space more than a woman I
think sometimes but not to say as woman
you can't but it's being aware of that
and I feel I have to assert myself more
Nicki Minaj says that sometimes if
you're a woman and you say and you're
assertive you're a if you're a man
and you're assertive you're a boss right
that's it exactly that so it's trying to
get done so definitely as well
interestingly we've got at the last
Academy dinner that we had there was
about 300 people there and over half
were women wow amazing amazing amazing
it is because I found sometimes in
property as a woman you're the minority
yeah it is immense yeah literally you
know if you go to it if you go to like a
Landlord Association meeting or it is oh
man it is all middle-aged man exactly
and then you're like oh here I am so
yeah it's it's definitely been um not
easy to navigate but being aware of the
differences has helped me to know how I
can present in those different contexts
how do you present different I try and
forget about that ah the fear and just
you know act as if and just hop forward
my point and say this is what I think
and and think less about what people may
think about me so it's just about that
and I definitely don't agree with the
people that say oh it's all in your head
I think I believe it's a thing but I
think at the same time I think there
might be advantages as well do you
what's that well well all right
um
now you put me on the spot no it's okay
I'll give you an example yeah you're
right I'll give you a real life example
which I'm very embarrassed to say but
I'll share it for the ability for the
value of the viewers I'm not very
Hands-On with cars okay and my I don't
even know what it was called but it did
I needed some oil in my car I was with
my wife Amanda and I couldn't get the
cap open and I was like man I can't get
a cup over so I was at a petrol station
and there was a guy walking past I said
oh excuse me he wasn't he was ah busy
but I said to him Amanda I'm like I
think you're gonna need to go and ask
someone for some help here because No
One's Gonna want to come and stop me I'm
a reasonably big guy they're just like
or if even if they did they'd just look
at me of just staying like what is your
problem you can't even get so so when
you're asking for help if or if I'll
sometimes I'll deliberately send Amanda
she's pretty lady and I'll just say can
you can you go and ask this can you and
and she'll get things where I don't feel
that people would give me the same time
the attention the help the support but
then I think also I can I agree with
your point sometimes people might be
stereotypical or they might think when
I'm a man says something it carries more
weight maybe and it's interesting
because really it's it's nonsense yes
men and women we're all humans and
you've got people in who are super
successful who are women in business and
you've got many that know anything about
business but there is a certain mindset
within property that men know what
they're doing it's a man's game so uh
yeah it's curious about your experiences
with that yeah but no no you're you're
right and it's true maybe as a woman you
can kind of who can have a bit more help
but again it's it's mindset because in
my own head and it's probably about me
asking for help I'm getting better at it
but for me I want to I feel that I want
to be in those contexts but that I know
stuff you know yeah so it's about how
you how you want to present as well and
how you feel that you're how you feel
you're received yeah and challenging I
think social norms as well or just those
societal Norms that you have in your
head and being able to just challenge
that and say actually that's what you
think but it's not that so let's you
know smash it in the ballpark so yeah
for me it's a lot of self-development
and mindset Samuels all about mindset
and just knowing what mindsets are you
bringing to this are they hindering are
they helping your progress so just
making that up did you find that as you
got more and more deals did you find
that you were more assertive and and did
you change yeah do you know I was
reflecting on that over the last couple
of days and definitely property going
into property in the last year has
shifted me so much as a person so much
the self-development the confidence the
you know being able to network in in a
way and not feel inferior as I had done
previously it shifted just my mind that
anything is possible and I'm no longer
scared of like zeros upon zeros after
numbers I'm just like it's just numbers
it's money but it's just numbers so it's
definitely boosting my confidence and
it's helped me in my work with
psychology the business side just
thinking you know the more you're You're
great and if there's something you don't
know go and find somebody and they can
help you to know it so in my head
there's no barrier because there's
always a way to find something out some
it's been life changing the last year of
my life has been life-changing yeah life
that's great and yeah I think as well
for me a lot of people say to me you
know you've changed my life but it's
more than me I've opened the door yeah
to a community yeah and to an
environment yeah you know and I think
that you know people sometimes people
say I'm shy and I'm thinking you might
think you're a shark but when you're in
a different environment with friends
that you know that are not judging you
you're the life and soul of the party
yeah so sometimes people think I'm not
confident in business I'm not good I'm a
shark I can't do this I love to pull
people out that I'm like I see something
in them yeah and then see them in a
different environment and that's like
you when you first came to the crash
course maybe I don't actually remember
because there's a lot of people but
maybe I knew what's this about but then
actually when you take you out put you
in a different environment and it's like
wow networking with Isabella securing
deals growing growing your bank but also
growing yourself
and I think you'll really if you don't
mind me saying but really gifted at
developing people so yes you create
opportunities but you're very gifted in
seeing where people are at and just
whether it's that one sentence of saying
you know that can kick somebody up the
butt and say you know go for it because
I remember you saying to me I think in
one Mastermind so you know Morris what
what's your next deal what are you
finding and I thought
but it kicked me to really go and find
right get on with those agents you know
find a connection and I ended up finding
a rent to rent in a couple of months
there's something about you know being
able to just coach and really help
people to be the best that they can be
when they don't necessarily see it
themselves you know so yeah I'm really
thankful to the property Network that
you've created but also the tools you've
given us through your experience because
I say to my husband we there's no excuse
for us to ever be poor because all of
these skills that I've learned it turns
money it brings money yeah how many
deals have you sold I've sold about 10
deals um in the last year
um and that's been with my business
partner um Isabella and even Matt Samuel
I oh I was thinking I don't want a deal
sell but then I realize having the tools
I was quite good I'm good at building
relationships I've got a very good story
that I share with agents that help them
to know that I'm reputable which I am
because you don't need to lie but you
know say who you are and people connect
with authenticity and also when you're
Honorable in business people can you
know really set and set out with you and
will then want to make connections and
do business because they trust you so in
seeing what all of my skill sets weren't
using property it's helped me to then
you know to earn to earn money yeah yeah
what do you think some of the
misconceptions are about business or
about money that stop people from being
successful I would say fear self-fear of
thinking oh I can't do it you know or if
they get it how do they sustain it or
how do they the money that they get how
do they create more that's just not
having the knowledge around that so I
think it's just around lack of knowledge
Samuel I think to answer that it's about
lack of knowledge but once you know how
and even if you don't know how it's the
confidence to ask and say you know what
I don't know how but I see that you know
you know can you help me you know
I see huge problems just in society with
lack of financial education with cost of
living crisis wages not going up and I'm
genuinely concerned for the average
person I I mean in London I think City
Khan said that next year the predictions
for the average rent in London is two
and a half Grand
but that that's not including Bells it's
crazy that's like a whole salary
gone yeah just on rent and said he can't
say we need to freeze rent and I'm
thinking well that's not going to solve
the problem we people need to actually
be thinking how can I make more money
even if it's in their workplace how can
I become more valuable how can I get a
pay rise how can I be more assertive how
can I be entrepreneurial how can I
actually produce more that's right and
we don't learn that in schools no we
don't and and that's why it's about you
know educating yourself outside of the
school system because I I remember
learning about Pythagoras I've never
used that in life but what I have
learned is how do you creatively create
different side incomes look at your
skill set you know with your skill set
you've got great strength how you know
how can you use that to turn money
everybody's got the the capacity and
potential to turn money aside from their
employment yeah and it's just knowing
how and also investing in yourself you
know getting a mentor joining a group
where you can learn more it's being open
to learning and not just thinking it'll
fall in your lap but sometimes you've
got to move your feet to find what it is
that you need yeah that's another thing
about education is that it's accepted
and celebrated if somebody goes to
University yeah right even if they're
going to University with no plan yeah
with no idea what they want to do and
they're just partying but they're
getting into debt to do it spending tens
of thousands of pounds everybody
collapse but then as soon as you go oh I
just spent a couple thousand on on a
property investment course where I'm
going to be opened up to loads of new
people on network learn loads of new
skills that I could an edge that are
going to help me become financially
independent in property people are going
to say that's crazy the mentality of
society is so warped and is is set up in
such a way that's going to keep people
poor I just find it crazy how as a mom
how are you gonna educate your kids
about Finance love the question a big
part of it is modeling so you know we've
taken them to our rent to rent where
they've sat playing their games whilst
we're decorating you know so bringing
them with us in the room and not just
saying what we do but them seeing
because they learn so much from what
they see us do rather than oh I did that
so bringing them in the room and then as
they get older can mine are quite young
then talking to them about how they can
get their money to make more money it's
not just about it sitting in the bank
but how can they go and build you know
interest on that what might they
investing and also risk-taking with
money that it doesn't you know it's
about taking yes calculated risk but
just nevertheless taking risks and and
also helping them to understand how they
can challenge societal Norms because
that's what it is it's all about what is
normal and what is the dominant
discourse out there but the reality is
to be different you've got to challenge
what the majority are saying and
sometimes they'll say you're mad but
actually when you get down the road
great decision so it's the confidence to
to be different to be different and
that's for me what one of the legacies I
want to teach our children be different
don't feel that you need to go with the
crowd because that doesn't always that
doesn't always cut it yeah be confident
to be you and be different do you reckon
if you had to have a thick skin I'm just
thinking because even even getting
property deals there's a lot of
rejection oh mate and then there's
family or friends or the stresses and I
think that a lot of people want to be
liked and they want everybody to just
like them and they just want to fit in
and be be normal and but actually when
you put your neck out on the line when
you put your head above the parapet yeah
people coming to chop it off real fast
well this is it and I think it's that
thing of just not worrying about what
people think of you but doing what you
know is in here and having the
confidence just to just to execute that
did any stories come to mind any horror
stories it did and I was thinking about
the failures that I've experienced in
business as well and sometimes it can be
a case of oh don't talk about those but
I've you know of late thinking actually
those have been my greatest learning
points and you know there are a couple
of situations just through relationships
that I had with others where you know
money wasn't exchanged and a bit of
money was lost but what I learned was
those were valuable moments teaching
moments for me about relationships with
people but also for me about
honorability in business don't just say
something but do what you say yeah and
so one of my values in business is The
Honorable if you're going to say it
fulfill it and if you can't then equally
say it so for me those are my learning
gems that I'm taking from from it and
I'll continue to learn more but for me
it's the failures have taught me about
well what are my values in business what
am I going to be renowned for you know I
want to be renowned for being you can
trust me that if I say something I'm
going to carry it through and if I can't
I'll say it but I'll be honest you know
Money Follows honorability yeah you know
when you're trying to duck and dive
I don't think you know it makes money
may follow for a bit but it's not
sustainable so for me it's about
building that generational wealth sure
yeah that's good that's a good lesson
what was the moment when you realized
that the whole property thing was was
working you're like okay this is working
now oh my gosh good question wow when we
started making money in the business
account I remember
um the property our first property had
gone live in the June and then by the
August we had like six seven K in there
basically from putting this property on
Airbnb and having contractors in I was
like my goodness this is literally you
know in less than you know eight weeks
so that's when it became real and I
thought this it it works it works and so
from that I never I never doubted
because it's about your capacity to take
something and make it real and apply it
yeah because you can have something but
not apply it and it not not be worth a
thing yeah so what for me it was that
conviction this stuff works just keep
going keep looking keep connecting and
so that will be my mentality is my
property career goes on just keep going
collection what does your mom think
about your success in property and
whatever you do she's so proud of me
even when I told her about today she
goes tomorrow I'm so proud of you and
and that means so much not just because
she's my mum but at the minute she's um
she's unwell she has cancer so for me it
just shows about you have time in life
and how do you use it how do you make
time count and so the fact that she's so
proud of me is because she's happy that
I've been using time you know in a
precious way and not just thinking oh
I'll do property next year the year
after it's like now is the time because
you know tomorrow isn't promise to
anybody none of us whether you're old or
young and that's what I've realized so
it means so much that she's proud
because she realizes that anything can
happen and so just seize the moment take
action what was like the strongest
reason that got you wanting to wanting
to start a property business I would say
the strongest reason was I remember I
was going on maternity leave with my
lost um daughter and at that point in
employment I just I just felt quite
frustrated I felt quite low emotionally
as well I felt I wasn't necessarily
being heard and then I thought I've got
two kids a lot of my time has been
sucked into my employment there must be
more and I know I love psychology
because I'm called to do it but equally
when you're given a family you know
you're also entrusted to raise them and
be present you know and so I thought
what am I going to do I'm going on
maternity leave can I learn something
new so in going to the cash course I
realize this is the vehicle to to use my
year to learn something new and to try
it and it's better to try something and
fail to then just think oh I wonder what
that would have been like so I literally
threw myself into it in my maternity
year without having to worry about
anything else in terms of my employment
or psychology and that's literally how I
how I you know how I made it successful
I just literally threw myself in and
said you know if I can make this
successful and have the option at the
end of the year to be in employment
fewer days and spend more time with my
kids than for me it's worked and so I
ended up going back to work just two
days so from working five four and a
half days to then giving myself the
option of just going back into
employment two days for me proper
property worked because there must have
been something yeah you know I think
property is a vehicle ah huge huge
vehicle huge vehicle and it's just about
having the confidence to try and
connecting because it works Samuel so
now I'm more entrepreneurial than I am
employed and I see myself in the next
you know year or so just being totally
entrepreneurial being in property and
connecting my psychology and property
together so she's so exciting I'm so so
excited about it oh and it and it will
be huge it will be huge and so you know
my husband's electrician as well so he's
very Hands-On and great with building
stuff so looking forward to that
Powerhouse how did you justify invest in
so much money into your education
oh it was definitely a game of faith in
my head because I spent that money I was
like Lamar you need to make this work
like you've spent you know 10K you need
to make this work it literally gave me
the impetus to just go go go get as much
as I can and I think if it was only you
know 1K or 50 Quid I don't think I would
have been as invested so it was the
amount of money that I paid that made me
think lamara this has got to work and
you've got to make it work fast and
since you know being in the academy I've
made my money back three times over it's
time now you're set up so you only have
to work two days well this is it exactly
so it's what I think it's what you're
required to invest in the outset that I
think can determine your level of
motivation and commitment so for me it
was because I invested that amount I was
like there's no place for failure and if
you're not sure you better go find
somebody because you need to make sure
you get you know get your money's worth
and I definitely got money's worth over
and over I'm glad we try our best you
know and I had a good time at the two
days coaching as well that was really oh
amazing wow amazing gosh it was a time
of where we were all together a small
group of us and we're thinking about
what are our broader goals for property
and just being able to learn from other
people's experiences but also think
about well what will my future look like
and so for me I left knowing that it's
about doing BRS and connecting that with
my psychology and just knowing that it's
all possible it's just about connecting
and and building those relationships and
seeing it through so it was just it was
character building and life-changing and
it was again all about mindset where is
your mind keep in mind positive keep
yourself in the right environment ah
huge thing what do you want to be
remembered for being honorable in
business and truly changing lives so
just through property so just yeah being
honorable being a person of their word
being trustworthy and just changing
people's lives not because of who I am
but because of the opportunities that I
can create for other people for them to
find out about themselves so those I
would say yeah that's what I want to be
remembering well I think you did a great
job and I'm I'm really glad to have you
on the academy because you've been a
massive asset and hopefully it wasn't
too bad coming on and I told you it
won't be too bad you've killed it and um
I'm really excited to watch it back and
hopefully inspire a lot of people so
thank you lamara thank you someone to
the team
[Music]